foreign
[Music]
relatives we are reminded of our
particular place on The evolutionary
tree The Chimps gorillas bonobos and
orangutans all resemble us in many ways
in both body and behavior
just like us orangutans are able to
learn from each other and they are often
seen using tools
chimps laugh when they are tickled
cultivate friendships and even go to war
with neighboring groups
gorillas have been taught to use sign
language and even use it to lie and
bonobos are quick to share food and seem
to be full of empathy
it's hard to gaze into the eyes of any
of the great apes and not see a
reflection of ourselves
however as much as we may connect with
our primate cousins it's been about 6
million years since the death of the
last common ancestor we shared with them
and since then humans have become
something quite distinct from the rest
our brains have more than tripled in
size during this time
and with our big brains we've become the
most dominant species on the planet
capable of writing novels building
skyscrapers and exploring the cosmos
we are simply not the same as the other
great apes
in the past few million years
individuals belonging to the homogeneous
experienced profound evolutionary
developments that now serve as the
foundation of the human race
these increasingly complex adaptations
have allowed humans to fully dominate
The Globe living in almost any habitat
controlling their very environments
but how exactly did we diverge so
drastically from the other primates
is it just our big brains that make us
so different or something more
what were the defining steps in the
history of our Evolution that made us
the walking talking thinking feeling
Society building Apes that we are
what were the moments that made us human
[Music]
for centuries the very idea that there
could have been an ancient species of
human that existed before our own was
inconceivable
even though many animal fossils had been
found through the years no early human
fossils had
the age of the Earth was still very much
disputed with most thinking that humans
were created in their present form a few
thousand years ago
even once Darwin published On the Origin
of Species in 1859 few believed the
concept of natural selection could apply
to humanity
Darwin himself was surprisingly silent
on the matter
but a pivotal Discovery Unearthed in
1856 during quarrying operations in the
neander valley in Germany would shake
the scientific world
pushing it closer to an understanding of
the origin of humans
while expanding the Mine Workers found a
partial skeleton of a male individual
the likes of which had never been seen
before
it was a specimen with an oval-shaped
skull with a low receding forehead
distinct brow ridges and thick strong
bones
the fossil was from an individual that
would have had a big brain like us but
its other features were quite distinct
although it certainly looked unique at
first even great minds like Darwin did
not believe the fossil could be an early
human ancestor but rather just an odd
Homo Sapien specimen
but soon scientists realized that what
they found was not a human like us but a
different species altogether
by 1864 the specimen became the first
early human species ever named Homo
neanderthalensis
this specimen was estimated to be 40 000
years old
several years after Neanderthal one was
discovered scientists realized that
prior fossil discoveries in 1829 in
Belgium and 1848 in Gibraltar were also
Neanderthals
even though they weren't recognized at
the time these two earlier discoveries
were actually the first early human
fossils ever found
these discoveries were just the start of
our understanding of the immense
evolutionary journey of humanity
soon after in 1891 another specimen was
found in Indonesia this time a much
older fossil
Eugene Dubois made it his life's mission
to find the missing link between
humanity and apes wanting concrete proof
that Darwin's theory of evolution and
the process of natural selection did
indeed apply to mankind
and his discovery which would later
become called the Java man would help to
cement our evolutionary story
the Java man's specimen had a pronounced
brow Ridge like the Neanderthals an
upright posture and a relatively big
brain however its brain was smaller than
the Neanderthals and Homo sapiens
this hominid would be named Homo erectus
and lived around 1.5 million years ago
at the turn of the 20th century
scientists began to draw the reasonable
conclusion that the unifying feature
between us the Neanderthals and Homo
erectus was our big brains that our
intelligence and brain size defined the
hominid lineage and set us and our
human-like cousins apart from the Apes
the Assumption was that large brain size
was a precursor to bipedalism that we
started walking upright to accommodate
our big brains
but soon this assumption would be turned
upside down with the discovery of a
skull of a small child in 1924.
a school so unprecedented it would be
called the most important
anthropological fossil found in the 20th
century
Tong child as it would be named was
found during Quarry operations in South
Africa
its brain was one-third the size of
modern humans so small that at first
scientists thought it was just the
remains of an ancient ape but this was
no ape one important feature of the
skull made this clear
the foramen magnum is the void on all
vertebrate skulls where the spinal cord
attaches to the brain
in four-legged vertebrates who walk on
all fours like dogs cats or even chimps
this hole is located at the very back of
the skull
in human skulls this hole is distinctly
in the middle
this allows the human body to be
oriented vertically for walking upright
same is true for the Neanderthals and
for Homo erectus
and the foramen magnum on the tongue
child it too was located centrally
the placement more similar to Homo
sapiens than to chimps or other Apes
Tong child would later be classified as
Australopithecus Africanus a type of
hominid that predates the entire
homogeneous
Tong child is estimated to have lived
2.8 million years ago
the fossil record seems to indicate that
Australopithecus is ancestral to the
homogeneous including modern humans
specimens discovered in the following
decades would help confirm the placement
of the foramen magnum on this species
among the most spectacular of these
discoveries was a fossil nicknamed Lucy
Unearthed in 1974 in Ethiopia
paleoanthropologist Donald Johnson and
Tom Gray found several hundred bone
fragments which ended up representing 40
of a single hominin
the skeleton included parts of the
pelvis legs and ankle and all of these
bones proved that Lucy Had a body not
only capable of walking upright but a
body made to do so
Lucy was classified as Australopithecus
afarensis and The Rock in which she was
found dated back to 3.18 million years
Lucy helped solidify the conclusion that
human evolution began with the adoption
of two-legged walking while brains were
still essentially ape-like
it is bipedalism that defines the
hominid lineage and was the first
evolutionary breakthrough that began us
on our journey to humanness
the first step to True Humanity was
indeed the first actual upright steps
taken
but how far back did bipedalism happen
in our lineage
some answers to this can be found not in
a fossil but in a few footprints
Mary Leakey and a team of
paleoanthropologists discovered a
remarkable number of footprints in 1976
preserved for millions of years by the
ash of a volcanic eruption
there were tracks from ancient giraffes
baboons rhinoceroses hippos and about 70
footprints that looked surprisingly
similar to those of modern humans
not only did the heel touch the ground
first in these bipedal walkers but the
feet clearly had an arch and a big toe
aligned with the other toes
these adaptations are all essential to
being able to walk by peterly
an arch acts as a shock absorber since
the foot is supporting so much of the
body's weight
in chimps and other great apes the big
toe is more like an opposable thumb but
for bipedalism it shifts position to
provide more stability and balance
it might seem like dating Footprints
would be even more challenging than
dating fossils but the latoli prints
were preserved in volcanic ash
freshly erupted lava and Ash contain a
form of radioactive potassium that has a
very precise half-life it decays into
argon and this Half-Life is used by
scientists to pinpoint the age of such
fossils with an accuracy of about twenty
thousand years using the potassium argon
dating method scientists stated the age
of the footprints to somewhere between
3.75 and 3.59 million years ago
given the clear evidence that our
hominin ancestors were bipedal before
they evolved to have larger brains the
next question becomes what behavioral
and environmental pressures led to
bipedalism
there are a lot of theories but no
conclusive answers at this point early
on scientists proposed the Savannah
hypothesis
other evidence in the fossil record
shows the climate in Eastern Africa was
becoming hotter and drier around 4
million years ago
the new climate changed the landscape
from Woodlands to more of a patchwork of
trees and open grasslands
this might have been the push that got
our pre-bipedal ancestors out of the
trees and onto the ground where they
could more easily travel on the open
land and reach other sources of food
like seeds from grasses
but in more recent years scientists
discovered an even older hominin
artopithecus ramadus whose Skeleton
shows some evidence of bipedalism Artie
dates all the way back to 4.4 million
years ago in Ethiopia when the habitat
was still very forested with more
frequent rainfall the fossil seems to
suggest that bipedalism could have
evolved when hominins were still
climbing the trees as well
other researchers have suggested that
bipedalism might be tied to particular
foraging strategies
from the ground chimps stand on their
hind legs to reach fruit in the trees
and this may have been such a successful
strategy for ancient hominins that it
slowly evolved into outright bipedalism
there is also a bioenergetic and
thermoregulation hypothesis
first humans walking upright expend 75
percent less energy than chimps who are
walking quadripedally
that means it would have been much
easier for our ancestors to cover long
distances than it is for more arboreal
adapted species
at the same time walking upright reduces
the amount of sunlight the body is
directly exposed to which was very
important in a hot environment without
much shade
the upright posture could have also had
advantages for social status
standing on two feet makes you look
taller and possibly more capable of
attracting a mate one researcher
suggests that the bipedal posture frees
up the hands for striking out in other
words bipedalism allowed for more fist
fighting which might have been an
element of males battling over mates
but perhaps most importantly bipedalism
freed up hands to carry things from
children to food to tools and Tool use
was the next big step in the story of
humanity
although there are no tools directly
associated with Australopithecus
afarensis the oldest Stone tools from
Kenya date back to 3.3 million years ago
which is when the australopithecines
lived
while we may not understand the precise
factors that led to bipedalism it's
clear that this evolutionary adaptation
was a watershed moment in human history
opening the gates for millions of more
years of profound and unique
evolutionary changes
The evolutionary story of humans is
unlike anything else and that's why we
made an entire series about it about how
one adaptation cleared the path for the
next allowing us to become the upright
hairless emotional intelligent and World
dominating Apes that we are today the
video you've just watched is episode 1
of our series becoming human and the
rest is available exclusively on nebula
the next four episodes of this series
discuss the major steps in human
evolution from Tool making to hunting to
long distance running to language to the
birth of Consciousness as we know it
nebula is the streaming platform we
built for exactly this reason to create
the original content that takes a little
longer has a higher production value and
explore areas that we want to take a
deep dive into things that YouTube
doesn't always value we can take more
risks on nebula and experiment with new
ideas and new formats as much as we want
there are many original series like
becoming human like Joe Scott's
Mysteries of the human body or Wendover
Productions extremities nebula has even
produced a feature-length film called
The Night of the coconut and a genre
bending award-winning play called the
prince which you can watch in its
entirety on nebula nebula is the best
place to watch this type of exciting
content from your favorite creators and
now nebula is also the place where you
can watch all of our videos two weeks
early so if you just can't wait for the
next real science video you can head to
nebula right now to watch our next video
about slime molds and how scientists are
realizing that they can solve problems
better than computers can and now if you
sign up with the link below subscribers
also get access to nebula classes you
can watch dozens of in-depth classes of
creators teaching you how to create so
if you sign up using the link below you
can support this channel directly and
get both nebula and nebula classes for
40 off the annual plan for just thirty
dollars for the entire year
foreign